move this a little bit closer how's this
different here me on the back okay
awesome well thank you for the very kind
introduction Alex I really do appreciate
that and I appreciate being here I love
coming here to Berlin I love Germany and
and I'm I'm also appreciative all of you
have shown up here at 9:00 in the
morning for my keynote so we're have a
good time so my talk is about rethinking
open source in the era of cloud and
machine learning and for me one of the
this is this a topic that's of course
very near and dear to my heart and I
think over the last couple of years
we've seen a tremendous amount of
conversation happening in the world
around open source around sustainability
and all these things and they're great
we need to be having more of these
conversations but as I go through these
conversations as I read the blog posts
and listen to the podcast and everything
I feel like there's some essential
things that are missing in the
conversation and specifically there's
some unique aspects of the conversation
that we can drive from within the data
science community and specifically
within the Python data science community
and so I'll go through that whole arc
over the course of the next I think I
have about 90 minutes is that correct
45 okay so over the next 45 minutes so
we'll get through it here like I said
these are comment I'm gonna assume this
is mine oh we're off to a great start
alright this is great I'm actually
finally over jet lag Lee notes that's
fine
did you do something to your coffee that
makes them undrinkable all right so are
we recording is this been recorded okay
you noted that first part out so anyway
we commonly talk about sustainability
right maintainer burnout commercial
users and one one thing that's
interesting I was talking to a friend of
mine and he said you know what's really
annoying now is that people show about
github and as opposed to be like hey you
did the cool project they're like hey I
need to use this piece of crap for my
job and like you need to fix this and
and so there's more of that right now I
think many people kind of can understand
that and then we've been trying to fix
these with like you know github as the
has their support things and there's
tide lifts and there's patreon and
there's you know things that we do it
anaconda and there's things that like
Quan site does and all these different
folks are trying to support in our
various ways so everyone's trying to
tackle these problems and then we also
of course have certain kinds of
unfortunate behaviors that we see around
commercial exploitation
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you we'll stop we'll start black
ok and then people are even and so one
of the defense mechanisms that's been
happening is that open source projects
have been starting to actually say well
you know maybe we need to change our
licenses we do things that are that are
more defensive in nature and that makes
me sad because I think there's something
wonderful about the openness that's in
the current sort of license as an
infrastructure and community so so again
you know I thought I had a 90 minute
talk apparently only forth 45 minute so
we have do this really really fast that
was a joke actually this will be 45
minutes one way or another so a
ludicrous speed so let's just break this
down so let's talk about open source
right now the the free software folks
you know they they have that famous term
free as in beer or phrasing speech the
open source folks don't seem to have
quite the same sort of pithy thing but I
like the term open better because
there's more you can do with it right
one way you can look at it is yeah it's
a free beer it's it's open and here's
well here the coffee you just drink it
another way to look at it is open means
while I can open the file you can open
the source code I can go and read the
source code now that's SiFi
okay size 170,000 lines of Python code
as eighty thousand lines of fortran 77
and most terrifyingly it's got a hundred
forty two lines of make so you know you
can read that source code but i don't
know if you really want to and even if
you do you haven't read the source code
for firefox or GCC certainly not for you
know any of these other tensorflow maybe
you read some pins of it but not the you
know core p c++ bits so when we talk
about open source in theory you know
being able to read the source is really
important right everyone talks about all
that but at the end of the day we're
really treating like a free beer we just
get this free stuff all right so happy
honest with ourselves I think about what
it is what's the actual value how we
actually interacting with with the open
source code another way of looking at
open you know the another
reason why I like the word open is
because you can do more with it and one
of the things you say as well open means
open to PRS open to contribution right
well that's great but in order to submit
a PR I have to read 170,000 so I thought
to make sure I don't break anything
right maybe it's really well factored so
all I have to read 2,000 lines of Python
to make sure I don't break anything but
that's a pretty big hurdle and again how
many people drink the free beer versus
how many people go in make the beer not
that many and and we can't we can't lie
to ourselves about that that relative
ratio of contributors versus users that
is what it is that meantime has proven
that to be the case how many people here
use an open source web browser Firefox
Chrome anybody how many submitted a PR
to Firefox or Chrome there you go
there's data another way to say is open
it's not just open to PRS but open to
ideas I give my feedback right and
that's true you can go to github used to
be your feedback to anybody I mean if
you if you buy software they have any
piece of software as a support for them
you can go make a comment on the App
Store if you want to you know so open to
ideas in our open source community some
projects are more open to ideas than
others and certainly if all if we have
the same ratio of user submitting ideas
to users not contributing code then the
projects thing is swamped so all these
theoretical definitions open sound very
nice and in fact I've used them in the
past and then you know when you really
go and hold yourself intellectually
honest on the stuff you're like well
this is all good but but you know we
have a very small ratio people that
actually contribute maintain the stuff
so the the thing here is just to set
things up I want to sort of challenge
you and and encourage thinking about
open source is more than just licenses
but really thinking about the basis of
empowering people communities to
innovate and and this is sort of the
underlying concept I'm going to be
carrying through the rest of the talk I
think open source software is best at
aligning users and customers and
innovators all of those that's that's my
key idea not that open source is about a
particular license
not that Oh anyone go submit a PR
because very few people do it's really
actually about empowerment and alignment
and I'll take that all the way through
to the to the very end one one thing
also that we should think about is that
in modern day and age software
and the code is actually because of the
nature of open source because github has
made coding so social what we have now
is an era where the software itself is
less of the important thing relative to
the API is that it establishes I don't
know how many people were coding like 20
years ago before we had a lot of social
coding but you would submit patches if
you if you participate in open-source
you'd be on mailing lists or using that
you would submit patches the diffs but
you would build larger and larger
software systems and you would work on a
system for many many years especially if
you're commercially employed you'd go
work on some like electromagnetic solver
or you'd work on some piece of like you
know 3d graphics software and you'd be
doing that for 10-15 years but actually
more more now people are using these
open source frameworks because they are
open they do so much capability there's
so much around like open source
frameworks like blender open source
frameworks like react you know all of
these different larger pieces of
frameworks the open source middleware
thing has really taken root so fewer
projects are monoliths more bolt-on lots
of little frameworks to make a thing
happen and one thing to be aware of for
younger developers is that this is
actually this kind of uber vacation of
the Giga vacation of the software
industry because it used to be that if
you spent 15 years working on monolith
you could really polish that thing down
it'd be really nice but then you also
become very irreplaceable right but if
we build them out of these modular
relatively fungible software middleware
pieces I can go out and say I need ten
react developers I need three django
developers and get 80% of what i need to
then do my work i'm not saying it's a
good thing or a bad thing I'm just
saying this is a dynamic that's
happening in the industry maybe it is
good maybe it means that the cost of
production of software is actually
cheaper but this is something that
materially impacts people's jobs and
it's really tied to the same shift
moving from code to privileging api's
and one thing about this that I will
point out is that there's a darker
pattern in the industry which is that
people will release api's and get people
hooked on those API is the oh you want
some middleware here's the middleware
for you oh you want a prediction API
here's a prediction API and now your
code is stuck on that particular API now
you're tied to that particular set of
services in that particular way of doing
these
so when we look at in the last you know
I think the last year so you know [ __ ]
Redis time a cockroach DB is some time
scale you know elastic all these folks
have been they've they've found their
open-source well they're open-source got
taken up by you know commercial cloud
vendors and produced as as commercial
services on those on those clouds and
everyone you know there's a lot of
wringing of hands about oh we open
source has the sustainability problem
what happens when a big player like
Amazon come along and swoop along and
take you know soup in and take all this
open source code from these hard-working
contributors and make it their own and
and actually I would I would say that my
thought on this is that this is not
actually an open source probably these
are business model problems because a
lot of these companies you look at their
open source that they produced their a
single vendor open source they of course
took contributions in from people on the
periphery but the core vision of the
project and the governance model was
always it always was housed at a
commercial entity and not out of
altruism but out of strategic business
purpose right they want any people using
those api's and then they would go and
their business model was to then
monetize that and they didn't close the
back door they didn't defend that right
by explicitly putting in like a GPL or
something they said well okay this is
totally BSD MIT license you can take do
whatever you want and amazon says ok
we'll take and do what we want right so
this is actually a business model
problem for these particular companies
not that I don't have a lot of empathy
for the hard-working developers who've
made all this code and didn't get much
from it but it's just you know we should
be very clear and are thinking and this
is not an ecosystem level problem its
particular few companies that had
business model problems and it speaks to
an underlying truth which is that when
we have stable api's when we have open
api's because to be very clear these
pieces of open source software give rise
to open ap is when you have open API so
they actually represent the kind of
utility where our Commons that is a
marketplace it's a really nice in
economics called a selling point it's a
meeting ground between maintained errs
between the you know the people actually
have to keep the code from bit rotting
all these things between the users of it
who just want to consume these things
and a different class which I'll call
the innovators people who want to say
well this is nice but gosh this could
structurally be so much better if I did
this so the difference between
submitting a small PR or small fix for a
little things you say oh this doesn't
work with this version of some public
API anymore and saying oh this is really
neat but you know what I want to do I
want to build this whole additional set
of capabilities and now I can do that
without having to reproduce everything
in this project there's there's a quote
that um you know science so Newton
famously said it's if I've seen further
as because I stood on the shoulders of
giants and so that that has become I
think you know basically the term is
science advances because you know
scientists stay on each other's
shoulders and there's a great great
version of that as computer science
advances by stepping on each other's
toes right and what open-source does is
allows us to advance by not stepping on
each other's toes lets us basically
climb up this ladder of success of
previous previous projects so how many
of you don't how many of you submitted
contribution to GCC for instance I know
one but how many of you have benefited
from projects that use GCC right all of
us and this is finally open source open
API is and not having to reinvent the
wheel from scratch every time in a
commercial entity this is what allows
that to happen it's what allows computer
science to finally let people stand on
each other's shoulders once again and
moment more importantly it's about
preserving choice and this is where the
free software people are fundamentally
correct it is a matter of choice it is a
matter of agency for the user and I'll
get to that at the end of the talk so if
we look at openness we say well open
it's not just about the free beer or the
free coffee but openness is not just
about you know you can contribute but no
one does then we should actually maybe
think about different ways of measuring
openness tied more to that freedom tied
more to the well functioning and the
smooth functioning of that market and
and you know here's just I'm just straw
Manning a few ideas here about you know
maybe if I build a bunch of if I build a
running workflow and it sits on top of a
bunch of open things but some of them
may be our proprietary open some of them
are like open but the the company you
know is the only one that can seem to
get the things stood up you know I can
sort of look at this whole thing and say
you know what would it take for me to
reproduce this entire deployment from
scratch from bare metal right or what
would it cost to change some course key
how I'm doing something all of these
kinds of ways are ways of measuring
openness in a non binary like is it MIT
license or is it some proprietary
license and I think this this Orient's
us correctly in the frame of thinking
about you know the impact a user user
choice how much freedom is the user
actually have so then open-source build
one step above that open-source software
right I don't talk about the actual
software bits and there's two I think
there's two ways to look at two kinds of
open-source software that we can look at
and and one kind is what I would say is
the traditional idea of open-source
software whether it's Linux or Emacs
maybe it's Apache
maybe it's docker right whatever it is
all of these things like I would call
classical OSS because they're made by
devs to scratch devs itches Dockers you
know what you know Linux was a little
project it wasn't like scratching an
itch but it was like yeah it kind of was
it was like you know Linus wanted to
play and then them and Emacs these are
you know there's a whole bunch of stuff
in good new that absolutely was
scratching an itch and that was Richard
Solomon saying I need agency I need
freedom
I don't want have to pay some you know
AT&T or whoever in order to use UNIX on
on a computer so they are scratching
itches whether they're feature itches
whether their philosophical itches these
are devs making stuff for other debts
right but in the SyFy and PI data world
it's kind of different these projects
almost every single one of them was made
by someone who is not actually a
formally trained computer scientist you
know the there's a saying I forget who
it was in our community I said it but I
said the the saipa ecosystem advances
you know one failed PhD at a time right
it's people basically trying to avoid
having to work on their dissertation in
the case of numpy actually is more than
that I mean Travis my co-founder Travis
elephant
he built numpy and basically failed to
get tenure he was on tenure track and
then he wasn't actually able to get
tenure because he wasn't doing more
valuable things like writing papers so
so I would say the SyFy and the PI data
ecosystem has has also been scratched
it's about scratching your own itch but
python was just good enough for these
people to take it and scratch a
numerical inch a
weird a weird sort of like yry don't
just use MATLAB or Mathematica right why
are you this why are using this weird
pearl like thing and these people lay
the groundwork for all that we do today
so there's another way to look at this
and and this is something that was
communicated to me by our former CEO
Scott Collison who was at Microsoft he
did open-source work after that he
worked in companies and started a couple
and at Microsoft he said we always felt
that open-source was great at solving
well-known problems okay and it's kind
of true a text editor I mean how many of
you love you max anybody here loves
Emacs all right
well screw you I like vim okay but
actually I'm just kidding let's not get
into it
Emacs versus vim is like worse than
Python versus our likes it's not even
get into it however what I will say is
text editors like kind of a well known
problem okay like text editors is you
build good ones you can build sucky ones
but in the general editing a text file
is a well-known problem right docker it
chose its own problem to solve in its
own way I would say it was a well-known
problem but you know a lot you can you
sort of maybe understand the sentiment
that a lot of devs making stuff for devs
they're solving problems that these devs
are like oh this is something I need to
do all the time people can see them and
I would say that the data science and
the numerical ecosystem again and
scratching its own itches it wasn't
trying to be way ahead of the curve it's
just doing its own thing but it turns
out the entire world needs all this cool
vector computing that they were doing
the entire world needs to do dot
products with matrices although we call
them tensors now and make more money so
you know it turns out that that just
happened to be lucrative I'm not gonna
take the luck part out of this equation
but I will say that in that space though
there have been really cool innovative
things that the people in the Python
community the open-source Julie
community and are there's been a lot of
really great stuff that's been done in
our community that is not well known
problems it's actually innovation but in
both cases and this is the important
thing whether you're doing innovation
whether you're just pursuing a
relatively commoditized and well
understood problem open-source
facilitates an open marketplace of ideas
right and and and not just ideas but
also some basic economics if you if
you're if you're looking at solving
well-known problems that
commoditized open source means you can
work with lots of other people so the
cost of maintaining this kind of not so
innovative but like important need
that's spread out across millions of
people that's really cool and then on
the innovation side you have a
marketplace of ideas so you rather the
advertising costs what you're doing is
paralyzing the search but as soon as
someone finds something they don't have
to go like if someone goes and makes a
really cool new visualization library in
Python they don't have to reinvent numpy
right they can take all the data frames
so you take all the array structures
they take many of the the work that's
already been done by matplotlib or
bouquet or whatever and build on top of
that so it's a free network intelligent
and network exploration and and so in
both cases we have an open marketplace
and that's a really really cool thing
about the about open source and about
the open API and I would actually sort
of just you know kind of jumping off
that point I would say the the PI date
on the SyFy community for the last
twenty years has been at that edge has
been at the vanguard pushing the art of
the possible right I know this is a
joined PyCon de and PI data Berlin but I
will ask how many people here have heard
of tensor flow now to basically know
what it does right good number of people
here how many people here have heard of
piano oh good we were very good piano
was doing basically the core of what
what tensorflow does right it was doing
it 10 years ago so you know this is this
is the kind of thing and if you look at
the performance of things like you know
Hadoop and the Hadoop file system you
know we had higher performance things
more performant things in the Python
ecosystem many many years before all
that so the the SyFy the PI data
community has been pushing the art of
the possible the last 20 years one of
the things that that I've observed in in
this process is that the successful
projects they're different in the SyFy
ecosystem there's actually a really
lovely thing that happens here which is
that the successful projects will tend
to limit scope they don't try to boil
the ocean and they they work well with
other people they try to interrupt so
for instance desk the desk project out
of the gate it tried to play well with
numb with numpy and with pandas it
didn't say well you know what hold on
we're to make our entire new sea library
for doing a race and also there's a
community aspect and this kind of
prefetches a little bit of what's coming
next but
but they they have reasonable leaders
like one of the really nice things about
going to scifi conferences since like
2005 is that I like hanging out with the
people like they're really great people
they're not like there's a few who are
just like they've got the rough edges
but you know whatever who doesn't but
but in our community there's not like in
general like raging wildfires of
toxicity from what I've observed people
actually you know a lot of people
there's there's a lot of folks with with
families that means very family-oriented
there's just a lot of really really
great stuff happening there and and I
think that's something that somehow
we've just again lucked into just like
the whole doing numerix in the numerix
are sexy now thing but but it's
something that I want to make sure we
preserve moving forward in a very
intentional way and another comment I
would make about this if you think about
you know we talk about open source has a
sustainability problem oh gosh it's
terrible there was actually a point in
time when I could literally 50 in the
course I PI and numpy maintainer is in
my minivan like if you look at how many
people and actually because wes was the
only one doing pandas you might as well
throw it west on the roof and then you
get basically Syfy numpy and pandas you
know in a Honda minivan so that you can
look at that say wow but these people
are all like suffering and struggling
and trying to make ends meet surely the
world is getting billions of dollars of
value from their software why can't it
just give them a little bit of just a
few million dollars a year right you
laugh but that's nothing that's a
rounding error for businesses we get
value from this stuff it'll it we all
know it it's true right you think how
many millions of dollars are thrown out
like random Java middleware crap you
know that would do a lot more for Python
but here's the important thing if you
flip that tragic equation the other way
around you look at that cloud on the
other side what you see is that actually
it's kind of amazing that a minivan full
of people can create billions of dollars
of value for the global economy that's
incredible right that's better than
capitalism so and and I personally I
think capitalism has its merits ok I'm a
refugee from Communist China I'm not
gonna I'm not really dissing capitalism
but but I do this is actually a really
deep point it sounds like a punch line
but it actually segues to the deeper
point moving forward
oh yeah there's of course
so that it is punchline sorry it is a
punchline but but before I get to that
next point I want to finish off the
section on software and and look at a
fundamental disconnect that I see in the
conversation about open source
sustainability in fact we had the panel
here yesterday of the you know core
Python maintainer Zand contributors and
and they're talking about how you know
people can get hired to work on Python
and you have one person here one person
there and again it's the same
frustration how many I don't even know
billions and billions of dollars every
day of value is the world getting from
Python and we cannot even extract a
fraction of a percentage of that to fund
the maintainer is doing such important
work and that disconnect I think is
because of a really actually a fairly
simple disconnect but is a deep one when
businesses look at open source right how
many people think the businesses like
open source because well I guess I
prefetch this denied how many people
here think that businesses like open
source because they get free stuff
they're free software come on yes right
it's a very it's a very straightforward
way look at it like you could pay for
Oracle or you take this free stuff right
people can take free stuff but I think
that's actually not actually the case
based on what I've seen in trying to
sell open source in this off into
enterprises because in the long run
businesses pay more to maintain they pay
more for developers building on top of
that software the licensing cost right a
hundred thousand dollars of software
sounds like a lot of money but if you're
paying one FTE like children dollars
it's it's it's something not rounding
error but it's a fraction of it if you
have a team of ten people building on
top of some database if you have ten
FTEs being paid market rates anywhere
you know in in any of the g8 countries
the cost of an Oracle license the cost
of a SAS or MATLAB license is a rounding
error so it's not really about the cost
it's not about the maintenance of the
software it's actually around avoiding
lock-in that's actually one of the
architectural decisions as made and this
is a really odd thing for us in the open
source world we think about you know
right now we've had so much gnashing of
teeth about Python to sunset right and
when do we stop supporting we have so
much hate about oh you forked the
community and you left Python you to
users behind and now you moving to
Python 3
the thing is that one instance that we
took 10 years to get over it happens
every day in enterprise software every
day they're energized vendors calling up
the customers saying you're gonna have
to pay to move on to the next version
we're not gonna store the old version
anymore so how the thing about the
amount of frustration that we saw in the
community around the two to three
transition every piece of enterprise
software every version every point Rev
creates that much stress and angst for
their customers and so customers who are
tired of this say well for this next
project we're not gonna use this thing
we're gonna use we're gonna use my
sequel list of Oracle or we're gonna use
Python is a proprietary language and the
reason is because then we have control
the enterprise's say we have now
sovereignty to decide when I'm going to
rev that project right if I don't want
to move off of some old version of
Django guess what I can hire some people
to continue maintaining that old version
until I make the transition on my
timelines that sense of freedom for
businesses is incredibly valuable and
that's why really at a sea level at a
SVP level why businesses are deciding on
open-source now in America we've been
leaning in open-source pretty hard I
know in here in Europe some mindsets
still have to take some time to change
but this is what I've observed selling
enterprise software in the u.s. now the
flip side of that what is the open
source community value what are the
values there well it's a gift economy
right we share with each other we give
our time we give our energy we pay out
of pocket to travel all over the world
to speed conferences and we do that
because we care because there's
something about giving that's deeply
meaningful and rewarding for us as
people and there's a culture of
participation which is why we is so
annoyed when someone shows up entitled
on a github issue and says just fix this
or like that and like this still doesn't
work for me it's like well ok like make
it work you know why is that my problem
all the sudden so participation invites
participation and in in reciprocation a
sense of entitlement free stuff free
support free code free free free that is
not part of our community values it's
antithetical trevallies that's why it
offends us so much and of course there's
an aspect of this because open-source
software many projects
they ship when it's ready what that does
is this shifts the emphasis on to doing
the right thing there's a there's a
there's a sense of quality and pride in
the craftsmanship around what we do as a
software community and and down here
like the the second section of this the
idea that the software artifact for the
open-source community of course when you
first start the code is very important
right you're working on the code as
community scale the software artifact is
a byproduct of a well-functioning
community the community isn't there to
stress itself out become dysfunctional
just to ship some beta on time and so I
think if it's like a community Orchestra
right the important thing is actually
that we play together and play together
well and if we do that then we'll make
good music versus the important thing is
for us to kill ourselves practicing at
night after a full day's work so that we
can put on a perfect rendition of some
Mozart you know concerto like these are
very different emphases but both
communities the open-source community
and what have values and cherishes and
the business community what they both
miss is a software isn't just about the
code software is actually a relationship
because software is not a fixed artifact
software is you know when you look at a
particular point Rev when you look at a
particular revision check in on in the
in the source code that is just one time
point in a stream and so how that stream
of alts how it flows that's actually the
relationship between the maintainer x'
between the innovators between the users
and the customers all the people who are
around that River then they've been in
shape the flow of that River and so it's
not about a particular scoop of water
you're taken out of the river and if we
do this right then we can get these
really nice stable patterns where value
is coming back into the water just as
value is coming out of the water and and
I don't wanna get kind of to nerd out
nerding out on this too much because
it's still just 9:00 in the morning but
I really want people to think about this
next time because many people I think
will look at pieces of software like
it's an artifact but I want you to think
about the software development process
that the process itself get more into
process thinking that
process is the relationship of energies
and attention expertise review many
different kinds of people and the
developers when you start scaling up the
software your product management process
is more than just scratching my own itch
right like for a Guido and now for the
steering council Python is much more
than just I want to do a cool project or
I want to like try to try to build this
new language to do this so even for the
makers and the innovators there's a
different set of energy they get there's
product management and product feedback
they get from users and that's really
important that actually feeds into the
river in a very important way another
thing that's really important is that
the the intersection of the the business
world and the open source world where we
have a problem is that open source
software really screws up the economic
thinking for most people because open
source software is not a normal kind of
property it's actually the opposite of
property because it's not scarce it's
fundamentally a good that is not rival
hrus and and you know the thomas
jefferson has this quote that
intellectual property are that copyleft
advocates like to use against the
argument or software freedom folks like
to use against copyright which is that
you know when my flame lights someone
else's candle it doesn't diminish my
flame but in the case of open source
software it's not just not diminishing
it actually amplifies my flame it lets
me see further in the room so it's it's
this weirdly anti rivalries thing the
more you give the more you get how many
other things material things in the
world can you point to metaphysically
real things can you point to that have
that property the more I eat of this pie
the less you eat right the more air I
breathe the more the more coffee I drink
the less there is for you right so most
of the material goods most economics we
have the supply demand curve we have all
these things that are set around
scarcity mindsets and rival risks sort
of games finite games not infinite ones
open source software represents the
transition the transcendence of the
software activity this intellectual
activity into a plane where we clearly
can see there's a generative aspect to
it the more you give the more you get
full-stop
so thank you and and you can see that
does not work with any kind of normal
economic engines or calculus that we
have even our terms about return on
investment and things like that
if your return on investment is not a
small percentage but it's actually
exponential and infinite what do you do
then no you know no bean counter with
the spreadsheet is gonna be able to
figure that out because that's not built
into Excel they know how to calculate
that when we get together in communities
like this when we sprint over the
weekends when we put our energies nights
and weekends organizing conferences
everything we do to help each other make
our community better
that's a generative activity it's not a
bean-counter thing and so there's a
there's a there's a really great tweet I
saw a while back that is a riff on
Conway's law and you know you hit a
certain level you send a certain level
of hubris when you start quoting your
own tweets in your conference talks but
but I just want to highlight this is my
pinned tweet for a reason that we how
many of you know Conway's law how many
of you heard okay so for those who don't
know it it's it's a observation that
this guy made back in the 60s when he
was studying software systems and he
said that the structure of piece of
software tends to mirror the
organizational structure of the people
that produced it right so if you go and
you have a system you want to build you
know is there perfect architecture for
it it's a perfect design I don't know
but if you hire three different Sultan's
to build it you're gonna end up with a
system with three different major system
subsystems if you end up going to it you
know if you go and give it to two
different teams it's gonna have two
major components and so this idea that
that code comes from people is sort of
like it seems like an obvious point but
it's actually a deeply important one
that I yeah in my tweet check it out
it's awesome
my tweet but this this idea that the
flip side of Conway's law is that code
is a cultural artifact so like I said
about the community orchestra how code
is an artifact for us when we play well
together we make good music it's about
playing well together more or as much as
it is about the music and so for me this
is a really deep point that when we get
together is open source software
communities the way we play is what
enables better innovation is what
enables broader search of the innovation
space is what makes
sustainability cheaper so this is a
piece that I want everyone to think
about software is not just about code
it's not just a single fixed artifact
it's actually a process in a
relationship and the communities that
produce software are very very important
because different kinds of communities
produce different kinds of software so
community there's a great book by Clay
Shirky about crowdsourcing called here
comes everybody and in it he talks about
the stages of collaboration the first
stage he says is it's kind of a weird
term use it's called me first
collaboration which is I want to vet
that this works for me scratching my own
itch as we would call it right
the second phase then and this is
crowdsourcing for anything could be
Wikipedia could be trying to build
Burning Man right could be like whatever
before you get like 50,000 people in the
middle of the desert you're gonna try
camping in the desert by yourself right
me me first collaboration so with open
source software same thing before I try
tell everyone in the world I've made
this amazing thing I'm gonna go and see
if I can make it work the next step then
is to have a place to have a
conversation with everyone tell people
about it people coming together to learn
and then the third step of course
collaboration where a group actually
forms and this is really important they
have a shared purpose they have a shared
purpose and then they can in their own
sort of amorphous way proceed towards
that purpose so you go from somebody
proving it out prototyping it then
having a place to teach other people
about it and then everyone getting
together to work on it pretty
straightforward but a generic pattern of
crowdsourcing that Clay Shirky talks
about a really important thing here in
this and this is a quote directly from
the book he says something very deep he
says it can often be characterized by
people wanting to fix a market failure
and it's motivated by increasing
accessibility it's very bunch of words
but it's like it's actually really deep
if you look at the ways that open source
whether it's on the monetizing taking
care of like well-known problems or
whether it's on the innovation side
open-source software fixes the market
failures of previous proprietary api's
that's the market failure
MATLAB has been around for very very
long time the amount of innovation and
people stepping on each other's
shoulders have on each other's toes or
only going as far up as the gravity of
the MATLAB license would let them that's
a very different dynamic than what
happened in Nampa and scifi pandas was
written by one dude working at hedge
fund and then he got another dude help
him and then boom a bunch of other
people joined in and now West the Oh
barely works on pandas at all right it's
been tamed by a bunch of other people
and that's great the unlocking of that
kind of human potential the creation of
a community like that they fix a market
failure around the previous the previous
old API is the old markets now this last
thing there's a fourth step which we
almost never get to the fourth step that
Clay Shirky talks about is collective
action the fate of the group as a whole
becomes important some open-source
communities get to a point of success
they have the privilege of being so
successful they're faced with that
challenge I would say the Python
community is faced with a challenge
right now when we talk about the future
vision for Python moving forward what
does that look like well it's a you know
global tens of millions of persons large
user community how do we do collective
decision making there how do we get
everyone's buy-in was the right model to
make sure we don't blow up the old
market but go into the new spaces and
try to create new markets that question
it's a privilege to get there to be
faced with the ability to climb that
mountain but is a big mountain to climb
and I think in order to climate we have
to actually have very very tough
straight thinking about what what we
what we want in the community we have to
get this trace not just about shippment
code is not just about fixing bugs in
triaging the bug tracker it's actually
about having a vision about the
community ethos itself and so you know
we need to actually make a seam and that
this is about participation this is not
just about getting free stuff get the
free stuff if you want to but if you
actually want to have a voice in all
this then you need to participate but in
order to accept participation of all
these different people we have to
develop trust with each other right this
is why diversity is so important this is
why diversity actually is the outgrowth
of a deeper principle which is
we have to develop empathy within
ourselves within our communities so we
can actually then have an inclusive
culture so we can actually develop trust
and this is why it's also today nowadays
it's very hard for you to trust
corporations or brands because those
come from very you mean corporate
culture they come from a particular kind
of consumerism particular kind of
capitalism a particular kind of
for-profit profit seeking rent seeking
motive so right now trust in our
community is still hair line tied
individuals I think for the Python
community to move forward we actually
need to figure out what are the ground
rules so that we can trust community
trust companies right and and a way to
think about this really is is I think in
a very simple metaphor is the thing
about as a community garden where we're
producing you know while tending to the
garden a few of us are it produces this
amazing verdant jungle of different
kinds of cool things and all this free
fruit is out there for people we put
that fruit a little basket and ask the
companies like please check out my
patreon please hire me right and not
only captures a tiny fraction of the
value of the fruit but that's ok we're
not greedy
we don't need billions of dollars but a
few million would be nice and oh I'm
serious
right like a lot of these open-source
software have added billions of dollars
of value why shouldn't the maintainer x'
have a few million dollars like that is
a totally fair fraction of the value and
another way to do it is to support you
know grocers people that actually strips
the span this chasm between the the
producers and the gardeners and the
people who just want to easily vend and
easily transact and a one framework I'll
try to give you to think about this is
it comes from a friend of mine who's
actually here in Berlin named Joe
Edelman and he says that there's in
general fundamentally there's two ways
we can look at anything in the world we
can look at it from a goal oriented
approach which is to say like I've have
a car this car is an object this car is
a vehicle I can use this car to get to
places right it's a good car cuz it gets
me into places this is a collection of
people it's a reasonable collection of
people and I can use it to go and you
know take my time my expertise and turn
it into dollars which I can then use or
euro which I can then go and use to buy
things like that that's a very
goal-oriented view of the world you can
view people this way you can view
institutions you can view any odd
literally any object right this coffee
cup right this coffee helps me stay
hydrated and also lets me talk faster so
I can get my talk done on time that's a
goal or interview of the cup of coffee
but there's a different way of looking
at the world which is to say how does
this object or environment or these
people help me live my values and it
ceases to be about process you cease to
look at things as mere tools I mean
problem with the goal oriented approach
and this is one of the most like damming
condo nations of corporate culture is a
views people as mere instruments towards
achieving some strategic key goal with
some key performance indicator but
really people we're people we want
meaning our lives right and for us it's
about living our values the open source
community is a great example of the kind
of generativity and the kinds of valuing
get when people get to live their values
and those values include technical merit
those values include diversity and
empathy those valleys include just
having a great time and being nice to
each other you know all of those things
are values that we want to live by and
that's a muscle we don't flex very often
but when we don't flex that muscle we
feel off sighted we know the feeling of
anomie when it relates to labour the
difference between effective labor
versus merely you know the the labor
economics of marx and all these others
so I think Joe Edelman this point I
would urge you guys to check out his
work but if we refract that then or if
we if we think about our our community
on the basis of that you know shipping
code is certainly a nice goal to have
but it doesn't Trump living our can't
believe I use that it doesn't override
it doesn't override having a meaningful
play a place to live our values so what
is the canoe philosophy right for the ml
era what does it mean to be Libre what
is what is compelled what is real
freedom what does generativity these are
the kinds of conversations we need to
have and they don't have to be global we
don't have to assert them to be global
they can be true just in Berlin they can
be true just in New York they can be
true just in India they can be true
wherever but the idea is to ask that
question to start with that question
what kind of environment do we want what
are the values we want to live in
express in this community and I think
the important thing you might say well
ok that's all great but geez this is
supposed to be a technical talk like
can't you tell us to show some code and
and actually I would say this is a
really important thing the reason why
when you get I think any of the
ecosystem maintainer Xand like the the
OG who like created these things he had
Travis up here he'll also be talking
about community values and diversity and
all these things and the reason we all
end up in this space is because of a
simple concept if you wanna make it very
practical and it's called go to market
right like when you have a product you
can say this product is awesome you
should use my cool widget because it
does these cool things that works for a
small early adopter community when you
want to take your product out to market
you have to explicitly think about how
does this product solve my users
problems you have to cross the chasm
with open source projects the same thing
I can get a bunch of early contributors
in and I see this in every successful
open source project there's an early
phase around the innovator community the
the bleeding the the kind of the
bleeding edge innovators and true
believers that the early adopters and
then there's a chasm and a lot of
projects they fall off in that chasm
they can't grow beyond that chasm
because to grow past the chasm you have
to go to community and you go to
community on the basis of values not on
the basis of tech now for me my values
in the pie data community in the SyFy
community and in all this for me what I
want to make sure we preserve is so this
is an articulation is just my answer for
this question is that we need to defend
the comments for innovation and the last
couple of years have actually been
pretty challenging for me because I've
seen very successful projects in our
community struggle I've seen other very
large commercially vendor backed
projects succeed and start attracting a
lot of mine share a lot of interest and
and they don't necessarily espouse the
same values that we have and I've tried
so hard to have come up with the right
way to express these concepts and
finally I've settled on this idea of an
innovation Commons and this is Elinor
Ostrom who is the best-known she's the
the best known person in the world about
you know talking about the Commons and
the tragedy Commons things like that her
researches and her writing his
foundation on the stuff she's
personal hero of mine but her work is
mostly tied to actual economic studies
of actual Commons with scarcity right
where you're defending a scarce resource
from the tragedy of the Commons but in
our case innovation creation are
generative and nonrival risk right I
mean if we have a big corporate project
that goes and does cool innovation that
doesn't stop you from going and doing
your project so what's the problem
and the problem in the Commons that
actually needs defending is the time and
attention of developers all of you the
humans the bodies the minds that is
actually a Commons and it's not linear
it's not that's super linear it's
actually exponential right ten people in
a room talking about a project is is
more than 5x the power of two people in
a room talking about a project and so my
concern the Commons that I wanted to
make sure our open community defends is
that I do not want to see that hijacked
by for-profit entities who do not care
about some of these other values that
were created this the PI data and side
by community so to put kind of thing on
it openness is embodied in the lived
values of of the community around a
software project as really really
important I want all of you to be
thinking about that when we talk about
open source it's not about how to get a
dollar here how to patreon that what
license do we use here source available
versus blah blah blah it's about what
are the values of the community that
produces this are those sustainable do I
believe that we'll continue to have open
innovation moving forward so open open
is a value about freedom and sovereignty
source is an outdated term
it used to refer to a time when just
reading source could guarantee you
sovereignty and choice of freedom not
anymore
you can read this piece of source
believed you only can get to work by
deploying onto a proprietary cloud yeah
you know have so much freedom software
software is a valuable artifact if
you're a goal-directed business but
developing it well is the primary value
for open source communities and lastly
community that's the most important
thing because social environment in
which we can live our values that we can
innovate that we can bring in more and
more great voices that's actually really
really important that's the most
important thing and and
you'll have to you know I guess that
there's Q&A period that we have after
after this and I can go through the last
section of my talk about why open wide
open is matter so much in the machine
learning era but just to preview for you
some you know cool stuff there so you
should come to my Q&A so thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Applause]
yes but yeah first thanks for the great
keynote Peter
yeah we move to questions so who are the
questions and Marie is going to another
section oh yeah we have another sex
session afterwards as well but if you
have immediately some questions we can
ask now okay then we move to the
everybody seems happy I think people
want to run to tutorials I also want to
comment before I ask everyone some oh
yeah you have the question so it's all
quite a lot about community and the
value of the community and extracting
that the somewhat hold for some of a
couple of million for the community do
you have any like practical advice on
how do we actually get that money into
the community yeah so yes that's a great
question so how do we get money into the
community since I talked about the money
so much I think right now the open
source community has almost a visceral
antibody like immune rejection of
certain kinds of businesses corporation
interaction things like that right for
instance when we think about you know
some projects like Python even right you
can't have more than two people in the
steering council work at the same
employer and you have other things like
that where it's like oh if someone's
getting paid for this they have undue
influence right what happens if if you
know Facebook hires Lukesh and then
tells them hey you but you got to go do
this thing and he's like well I don't
want to do this thing so we sort of have
a sense of anti patterns around this and
I think that the way we can get the
first step to unlocking dollars or money
for this kind of thing is to actually
change the conversation to be about
values as opposed to being about certain
kinds of influence to say well if these
companies are aligned with our values
then we can take their wheat then we can
actually do things for them it's not
inappropriate to say you can pay for
roadmap as long as that roadmap but
here's to you know is really pushing
certain values maybe you're paying for a
new innovation
a exploration of this project right
maybe you're paying to maintain some old
stuff paying for roadmap paying for work
is a-ok right well we what we have this
like immune response to is the idea of
paying to move the community and shape
the community and just like you know
that capture is what we don't like but
if we just express it on those terms and
think of ways to have that conversation
with business many businesses are happy
to pay for those kinds of things they
don't want to screw up the innovation
they don't want to screw up the
community dynamics right so I think
that's the first step is coming up with
a values based discussion with business
okay so with the closed position but we
have a QA section in the launch
so please just come there Peter will be
now or later
no yeah after the next session after
next session just in the lounge and
thanks for coming thank you
[Applause]